now the party continues in florida for
blue state democrats with california
congressman eric swahwell being the
latest liberal lawmaker to go mask-less
in the mandate free state
joe concha here to weigh in joe swoela
literally lives in one of the most
popular vacation destinations if you
want to get sun that is the liberal
state of california so why would he fly
his family all the way across country to
that horrible no-good conservative state
of florida
that's the thing if you're say a
congresswoman from new york for example
you you want to get out of new york in
december and january because of ice and
snow and cold and wind and so on if i
already am living in california and
believe me san diego la jolla those are
two of the most beautiful places you can
go to as far as vacation malibu anywhere
in southern california you have
everything you could basically get in
california even if you want to take your
kids to disney world well there's a
disneyland there so
why even fly
3 000 miles across the country to go to
florida of course swalwell does that
perhaps because maybe he could then sit
somewhere without a mask on he could go
into a restaurant without offering up a
vaccine card maybe it just feels more
like a vacation in florida than it does
in california and it speaks volumes as
far as democratic lawmaker after
democratic lawmaker remember gretchen
whitmer michigan went down to florida
after telling people literally in her
state not to go to florida because of of
all the vaccine non-mandates so
it is rules for the not for d's in this
case the d's of course stand for
democrats
okay i do want to get to this um this
was one of the ladies from the view
whoopi goldberg she was just absolutely
stunned after she tested positive for
comet i want to listen to the sound bite
and then we'll get your reaction on the
other side
you think i've done everything i was
supposed to do yeah it doesn't it
doesn't um it doesn't stop omicron and
that's the problem with a variant
because it gets stronger and does
different stuff to you
two things um i i don't want to take any
type of medical advice from whoopi
goldberg but uh can we stop calling this
a pandemic of the unvaccinated because i
feel like at this point if you don't
realize that this is affecting the
vaccinated and unvaccinated you've been
living under a rock
yeah and and whoopi as well said that
this variant is stronger the data that
we're seeing actually shows that it's
much weaker as far as the ability to
kill people or hospitalize people right
omicron is very contagious yes much more
contagious than delta or any other
variant but it's certainly uh not
something that is stronger in terms of
its ability to make you sick look maybe
whoopi took the president at his word
when he told a cnn town hall last year
quote you're not going to get coveted if
you have these vaccinations unquote what
would be getting covet also shows is
that no person should ever claim again
as mr biden did as a candidate that this
virus can be stopped that it can be
contained new york city for example this
is a remarkable number here they're
averaging now 40 000 positive cases per
day that's despite the fact that 85
percent of the city's population has
received at least one vote dose of the
vaccine it's a highly vaccinated city
okay so think about it 40 000 cases per
day now do you know what new york was
averaging exactly one year ago when no
one was vaccinated outside of health
care workers 7 500 cases per day about
six times less so this variant again
it's highly contagious
but we need to be talking less about
vaccine mandates and staying at home the
mass everywhere and more about
therapeutics and living with covet
through treatment and going about our
daily lives particularly when it comes
to schools i hope a lot of people in
chicago are watching right now
it sounds like somebody's married to a
doctor joe koncha
thanks for being with us as always and
give our best friends don't drink coffee
out of a.m we appreciate it
thank you man yeah you yeah you got your
tie
i know what happened contract you got
the pie i went to brian kilmeade i want
you to do me a favor i want you to click
to subscribe to the fox news youtube
page this is the only way that i know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now